oh yeah
dude i love those sounds that um
come out of your body that
kind of like
you know if you see like a
sometime i was sitting on a bench
somewhere and i think i was at a um
outlet mall and if you've never been to
an
outlet mall it's basically where
people really people that love each
other unconditionally go to
kind of waste money on that doesn't
fit
you know you'll see somebody with like a
um
you know you'll see somebody with a one
shoe that they it's like a size 10 and
the other one's a nine
but they don't you know they're not
really they don't care that much i guess
or they just they're willing to deal
with it
for the price at six dollars you know
you'll see somebody with a neck brace
that says estee lauder on it just
you know people want things that have
just big insignias on it
you know for four dollars you'll pay
somebody just to damn paint levi's down
your arm
or to um
you know you'll get uh for 50 cents
baskin robbins will give you ice cream
that is scoop it right into your hand
you know they just it's like a halfway
house for um
capitalism basically
you know you'll see a damn uh lacoste
shirt over in the distance over in the
you know in the parking lot shooting up
in the car
by himself he's over there just dousing
up
so i don't even know what i was going to
tell you guys but i'm uh
i'm happy to be here with you and i'm
happy that i'm not at an outlet mall
right now
you know i when i was a child we liked
hitting that outlet mall
you're on your way to the beach you got
17 burning a hole in your pocket
and you want about 30 items
you could get a shirt that's made out of
all collars there's no
you know they messed up in china or
somewhere
and they just damn it's just full it
have collars on the arm so
your your neck has a collar and both
arms have a collar
you're like damn this this is a real
professional shirt
you know you just that's the kind of
stuff you see
you'll get a baby diaper there sorts
coins
and they'll give you that for 58 cents
67 77
it's just that kind of you know
you can get a soda for for 60 cents but
there's no cup involved they just
pour it into your mouth drink as much as
you can
and i'll have a store say unlimited
beverages
we'll douse you up we'll douse your
daddy up
yeah it's a lot of sun burnt people
um a lot of non-bitcoin owning
type of people i feel like just regular
people
you know a lot of people that have been
involved in domestic disputes better
in but now they're going to the beach
and on the way there they stop and uh
and get a little dose of that come up
you know that
and i'll say this man no shade to
britain i know you guys sending um
whatever his name is little marky or
whatever that guy's name is
uh prince harold
y'all sent in his little ass over here
with his trifling lady
and we sent her over there y'all sent
them back
you know apparently the current the
import export business is just
just we're just all just sharing a bunch
of you know it
and uh and i'll say this man a biscuit
would beat the hell out of a scone
and you could put that on your great
granddaddy's damn doorstep dude
unless y'all sold his home after he died
no shade baby let's come up baby
gang
this is eddie 9v with the come up
and that's 9 volt
[Music]
um
well i just broke up with my baby
[Music]
nothing
well if you're asking me what i really
want to do is just come right back make
love to you i'm gonna come
[Music]
there you go baby
volt filling me
[Music]
filling me man
filling my cornucopia
remember that deal they taught you about
it
back in elementary
they taught you a cornucopia man it was
a damn little
i don't know what the hell it was get a
basket you know it was just a damn it
didn't
you know it was just a greedy
it looked like a damn oysters little
side piece or something i don't know
what it was
man the cornucopias and they
they've
stuffed them with carrots and all kind
of
and it just it was too much to i
couldn't handle i didn't know what was
going on
it looked like a
it looked like a seashell like a damn
gay seashell or something
or a sexually curious you know
or big curious they call it it looked
like a big curious seashell
trying to have a salad or something at
one time
and that was cornucopias man um i'm
gonna come
up that's 89 volt
god is a good tune isn't it
and thank you guys for being here today
uh
we are here and that is the choice that
we made and i'm grateful for it
what's going on man a lot of little
deals
you know you had the floyd mary weather
and um
uh po uh
logan paul went at it and it really it
kind of had a um
i mean logan paul come in he came in
hella german on that fight when you're
looking at him
real swedish very viking very like damn
this fell owns an axe type of look
you know and uh
i don't know you know i don't know if i
like watching do i want to see
millionaires fight each other i want the
underdog in there
i feel like
and i guess you know floyd has accusings
of wife of
uh you know you know he's beat 50
50 he's 50 you know seven of his wins
came against ex-wives
allegedly and so
you know maybe that's what you want to
see i don't know i was just wondering
what made me want to know i was on the
airplane i i
there's no streaming on there so you
have to just guess what's happening
which is you know it's like the old days
really
you know it used to be like what
happened somebody tell you they
described it
dude it was lightning and then a guy and
then
no he couldn't even i don't know man
it's unbelievable
it's on my way ball
but then it's you know it just gets
different you know and now it's like
there's just so much you get so many of
the recaps and stuff but i'm on this
plane
i'm trying to get the thing to uh stream
it wouldn't
but about every 55 seconds it would give
me a um glimpse
just a jpeg just a bam
and uh yeah and so
you know i had no idea what was
happening it looked kind of like a
couple of square dances look a couple of
young men
that had met somewhere and was doing
drugs and you know
probably at a men's club a nightclub
called splash or fade or
joy a lot of usually the gay club in
town has that you know kind of like um
it's never like care bear ernie's
tug it out boys shop or something you
know i
someone i wish they would go with a more
vibrant name a lot of gay men
night uh
you know drinking holes water holes
bars but they don't you know they
they just kind of it's always like vibe
or
uh glisten glisten is kind of a dicey
when i feel like this
i don't know what that's that they're
doing in there but
yeah we had i'm trying to think spray
was one you're like that
that's that seemed like a tough bit
oh but yeah i tried to watch on the
airplane i couldn't do it
i could not get that thing to uh to load
up in the function
um and so i just got a glimpse every now
and then
but that's what the one thing that's
interesting the old days you know i feel
like that's how
storytelling really found its
that's why storytelling had some value
it had some limbs on it
you know it had some legs
because you had to tell a story
what happened to ronnie you know oh
you know ronnie got uh
ronnie got his ears pierced man
you're like damn really he's a you know
he's a father of four and he's in his
70s and the people like yeah well
you know he likes boy bands you know
he got to they caught him in his truck
crying in his truck with a
o-town poster and then
and then he got him pierced so
um but yeah just you had to tell a story
everybody had to well what happened
something
you know they remember paul revere's
that fella
you know the original drunk driver that
dudes out there just
rolling across the central east just
screaming yelling
you know just but you had to hear you
know people used to have to tell the
story there was a value to
somebody coming into town tell me what
happened
oh you were there to share it with me
it was different before we had all this
mass communication we all had such a
value i feel like
because the story of the world
and the story of
existence
it was all
it needed all of us
and we still have it we still iterate it
but there's not that moment-to-moment
value
in everyone where you're like oh tell me
what happened
oh you got you you're not man y'all
ain't gonna believe what
it's just you know now with so much
videography
it's just a different time um
but i don't know why i don't know why i
said that
i guess i was just kind of thinking a
little bit
you know what's going on i got a
smoothie
um i'm back out here in the central east
you know when i got me a smoothie and oh
i took that first sip and
it's one of the healthy ones man and it
uh
god it just i wanted it i want it
it's a little too healthy you know it
kind of tastes like i'm just
like i stuck a thing into a plant and
i'm just
sucking that big
like i'm just just giving it
just really just giving that freaking
that little baby hummer to uh
to a plant you know like i'm just damn
taking down a damn
uh begonia or something face fir you
know i'm just
doing oil on the begonia this thing just
heavy
i mean it may have dirt in it i have
that's the thing you go to some of the
smoother reason it's too healthy
it's too it's just like come on they
just go too far with it
you know it's just too much they just
like some of us just too healthy
man you know you know they have potting
soil in it
they'll have semen from uh slovenia
in it you're like what
you're just like damn man you got to
kind of should make you suck off a
bag of carrots after you have it you
know it's just some of it's just getting
too healthy
i missed the original smoothies that
thing was mostly sugar dude
and then they'd hit you with two scoops
of uh protein powder
and they'd have like the one dude in
town he was like oh
i work at gnc on full
eating meat right now in my head
he would record himself eating meat with
a video and then just
play it back while he was eating while
he was also eating meat later
you know he'd have at night he would
sleep next to an audio of him just
sounds of him eating meat his names guys
got bacon brain man
what else is going on i went home to uh
louisiana
you know and it was uh uh uh uh un
un un unjoyous circumstances really man
had a
childhood friend that passed away
you know when he died of drugs and doing
drugs and
you know it's kind of uh it's kind of
wild when that happens uh
and i know it's happening for a lot of
people out there
a lot of people struggling and a lot of
people's friends and family struggling
and
you know i believe that there's some
people that suffer from addiction
and then there's some people who are
somehow victims of
you know these large pharmaceutical
corporations and they're just throwing
pills and everything
you know you go to starbucks and get a
muffin and you know
you could get a damn they'll do
blueberry zanbar in there
like what it'll be pineapples and soma
like what that's a mix that's a mixture
now
this muffin brought to you by damn uh
uh monteverdi or whatever those big
companies
it's monsanto like gee i don't know
should i eat this you eat it
you're just used to it you know you out
there
knobbing on a couple monsanto muffins
dude now your mustache
won't grow you don't know what's going
on your tongue smells like soy beans
anyway man yeah i had to go home this
buddy will was a friend of mine and he
passed you know
and it was just interesting man you know
um
you know it was a lot of things it was a
lot of people i hadn't seen in a long
time
and some of you may know you know i
spoke over the years about this
gentleman
and he and i you know uh we were friends
when we were young
when there was not a lot of people in
our town and
you know back when you can still hear
the train come through
and back when if somebody was on the
train it was a you know a decent person
now the train pulls up dudes
it's a bunch of just damn
you know anybody could be on there now
it's mostly robbers only now on the
train you
let me put these shades back on i like
them sometimes you know
it's almost like i'm in mourning a
little
and um you know you may
this fellow this fellow i grew up with
there was a time in our town when
somebody got a hot tub
and people had never said they couldn't
imagine what what what is it
somebody's like it's like a little ocean
in your yard and it's
you know you put a damn
you know it's like warm it's like a
little damn soup
and so people were fired up you know and
and opening night i didn't get to go to
opening night at it
there was more adults going there and
seeing it and drinking wine buy it and
you know people would press a button and
turn it on
and then turn it off like oh look at it
they'll gotta have what's great
you know people bobbing for apples in it
you know drinking and then
maybe your buddy's wife's over there
bobbing and nobody's looking and you go
touch her ass a little or something
or play crack hand or something for a
second with her you know or whatever i
don't know
i don't know what the neighborhood was
like i didn't go to opening night
but the next day they let the children
get in it
you know when i was a child and so i got
in there and
you know we're all in there and we were
children man as many many kids as you
could fit into a damn little hot tub
and this i think this fella this thing
probably seated seven i don't know
when you're a kid everything seats seven
seventy seven hundred
you know your children so it doesn't
matter if there's people next to you or
on your whatever
you know little lawrence will be in
there and he'll be wearing little
freaking anthony as a scarf and
they got nine other kid you know they
got twins in there and
somebody goes in and comes out as
triplets it doesn't who knows it's just
being children that was just
you know the the connective energy
amongst children is
it's not as it's very strong
you know as we when we get as we become
adults i find i
become more of a proton or a neutron
but when you're young you're just part
of the electricity
so anyway we had a bunch of children in
there and
we'd never been in a hot tub people
didn't know you know people drinking the
water and doing all you know washing
their hair and
one kid you know his dad come over and
baptize him on the side and people just
living one fellow brought a fish it died
immediately because of the heat
but people didn't know we didn't know we
weren't enjoying it
and the directions got all wet
immediately so nobody knew what they
said
and we were just hot tubbing and
pretending we were in fans somebody
wrote tahiti on the
on a sign and nailed it to the tree
right there and god we were living it up
and there was one fella named cj
and he was older than us he was probably
he could have been 15 he could have been
60.
you know he had those he had scars on
his back i don't he might have been a
slave
you know he's a white guy but he might
have been enslaved at one point i don't
know he'd been through a lot
you know he'd been through a lot and i
remember he had hair kind of around the
top of his pants on the back
and uh so anyway we're all in the hot
tub we're enjoying it we're probably
maybe
10 or 12 i don't know 11.
and big cj been under the water he'd
been touching his body
you know and he'd been prepping his body
to really e-jack out
and spray you know i'm really just
bust full you know
and i'm not a pedophile or anything i'm
just telling you a story from my
childhood
so you know i was there and i was a
child and when this happened anyway so
he
he's prepping his body under water the
rest of us don't know we're doing back
strokes
you know we're doing uh one guy's
filling his mouth with water
shooting it in the air somebody else is
catching it
you know people just having a good time
it's like a little las vegas out there
it's like our own little uh
uh bellagio you know we're doing it all
and cj been prepping his body to bust
out well at one point he stands up in
the hot tub and ejects
out into the water and we've never seen
it
we're like what we've never seen
you know i think i'd only ever even seen
anybody else's penis but probably my
brother
i'd seen my own penis in a mirror but
that's just your you know that's still
your penis it's not
you know it's still yours it's just one
and then i'd seen some other kid's penis
through like a fire he was on the other
side of a fire and i was on one side
but um yeah this kid
stood up and he knew about it
and he so he you know he's e-jacking out
into the pond or whatever and uh
and my buddy will was right there and
will was a sweet guy man and he just
he he thought something was happening to
this kid
to this cj but he thought he was dying i
guess
you know he thought well if this you
know
if he pumps out another
20 or 30 servings he's gonna you know
each time he gets gonna get smaller and
smaller he's disappearing
you know and i could see in that moment
how that all registered it was like oh
my gosh this guy's
you know this guy's uh eventually his
whole body will shoot out of the end of
his
wiener so we didn't know what to do man
so will grabbed it
will grabbed it to really stop it off at
the end like a hose you know like where
you
bend a hose like that and the fella
punched him man fell unloaded unloaded
on him
so and that was a lot man that was a lot
for one moment in time because we never
i'd never seen any of that i'd never you
know to see
such you know a moment of kind of sexual
advancement at that and experience that
and then also
see a saving you know this real saving
grace this real
this two-handed angel you know come in
and try to save this boy's life to keep
his
body inside of his body to keep him
from just dripping out his existence
into the world and then to see the
the abuse at the end and you know it's
kids man
and that's kids brother but uh
but god man
god life is uh
there's a lot of gravel on the road
isn't there
and will we love you man and i just want
to let you know that you are loved
brother
and uh and you'll be missed man you were
always
you were always up for the up for the up
for a good time man i feel like you were
always
and not just any time you're always
pretty positive man and hopeful and uh
and you will be missed um
i gotta let you know we got tour dates
we're adding shows coming up those will
go on sale i believe next tuesday
and we are adding shows in cincinnati
durham
chattanooga knoxville minneapolis
charleston and columbus
so just letting you know now you can
follow that information through
instagram and through the podcast as
well
as well currently we have shows in st
louis cincinnati charlotte
durham north carolina over there where
my mother uh
attended college chattanooga
uh where my mother lived actually on a
mountain or on a hill over there
before they had fallen out knoxville
tennessee
um wilmington delaware wilkes-barre
minneapolis finally getting back over
there to prince's hometown
charleston south carolina where i uh
went to college for one semester and
and i used to work at frozen options
over there
where they had good smoothies and and
dirty uh
where we didn't fully clean out the only
tanning bed in town
and people got dysentery and um pink eye
out of there
because some fella budded out in there
one night came in their home
you know after a night of doing cocaine
desecrated the thing with his butt or
whatever and we didn't clean it
very well richmond baltimore albany
we will be there uh all the dates and
all the tickets should be bought
through theovan.com tour that's where
you have to get these things because
other places are it's ridiculous links
young lady sent me a thing the other day
you buddy
you i'm trying to take
arnold and i guess that's her husband or
whatever i don't know trying to take
arnold to see you and each ticket's 260
bucks
you and and then she called me the n
word which is fine
you know what i'm saying i don't mind
being called it once in a while but
you know i it just was like i don't know
i guess i i mean i was right i'm always
ready for it but i just wasn't
you know this seemed egregious but
anyway
and i wrote back i said we'll just get
you a ticket from a regular locale
woman get you a ticket from a decent
locale
because you're shopping in decently on
random links
that's all the links through tour
taking you appropriately priced tickets
everything else is
that's cat ass baby that's cat ass
and i don't mess with cat ass man
i also don't mess with paying too much
for insurance you know i'm redoing the
insurance on my home right now
and i'm excited about that and my
azaleas are doing good
and i want to thank producer sean who
goes the extra mile sometimes when i'm
out of town and
and help me get the azaleas well keep
them well and those are doing
well
and i'm grateful to be alive man and
i'll tell you this story so the other
night i go for a swim you know
and i go for a swim and um
and i'd had me a little bit of blue chew
i was testing them out
you know i was testing them out because
and look i'll be honest with you i gave
a fellow one after a show one time he
said he was going home with his wife it
was their
sixth anniversary or something i said
well you got on this you know
year six you gotta get back in there
you know you gotta you gotta do a little
bit of uh traveling
you know what i'm saying you gotta
torque out big dog
you know what i'm saying when she asks
where you are you say i'm up
stay
and she'll know don't be all don't you
know
you could downstairs for years kind of
two through four but on year six you
gotta get back
upstairs blue chew
is making waves and bringing more
confidence to the bedroom
by offering chewable tablets that can
help men get stronger and
longer lasting erections now sometimes
you gotta thorn up
you know sometimes you gotta thorn up on
somebody
you know when a lot of men will do that
that that's
they'll put a glove on their wiener say
hey shake my hand the lady realizes all
day
that's a wiener and a glove
blue chew is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations hey
uh you know um i was
uh
yeah none of that man i remember i went
to a dang guy one time and they had to
do injections into my penis to make sure
it worked
no waiting in line at the pharmacy and
it ships right to your door in a
discreet package
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription
within days within days that's the best
part
it's all done online that's true
you could benefit from extra confidence
it's time to perform visit bluechew.com
for more details and important safety
information these things do work
here's a special deal for our listeners
try bluechu free
when you use our promo code theo at
checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's b
l u e c
h e w dot com promo code theo to receive
your first month free
and we thank blue chew for sponsoring
this podcast
you know i've been struggling recently
also with staying active and staying
mobile
and my body gets tight and sometimes i
just need a damn
strong-handed woman i need a big german
to get on there
you know or a big slovak baby
you know we're a big urban just to
really just
douse my muscles out with their strong
that's hands and when i get
limbered up then i can really take care
of myself workout wise
that's right what i want to tell you
right now is peloton
yep pelaton
world-class instructors curated music
endless
variety peloton has created an unmatched
fitness experience
that keeps you motivated workout after
workout
yup that's right peloton gives you
that that that vitrol
that salute that that
when you know when you are doing peloton
that you are doing the best
that's right whether you're looking for
some extra encouragement structured
workouts or just in the mood to laugh
their instructors are there to bring out
your best during each class
you know i've had instructors that don't
do nothing over there
some girl over there over over there
took her temperature the whole time
and then said she you know was ovulating
or whatever and she had to go home to
her husband
like what i'm here to do carl's
so things change with epic artists
collaborations in an instructor-curated
playlist
their music experience is unlike any
other whether you're in the mood for
some hip-hop pop or country the peloton
bike has the right music to keep you
entertained and motivated
all year long peloton also
offers their all-access membership it's
more like a family plan for no
additional cost that's right no extra
so if you got little uh larissa or a
little uh
little tiffany wants to do something do
a damn leg up or something or a damn uh
you know a couple tilt-a-whirl sets or
something
now that beautiful bra can stay fit as
well for no extra cost
bring home the peloton experience for
your whole family with access to their
entire class
library yep classes for every level from
beginner programs
to tabata intervals peloton meets you at
every step in your fitness journey
get started on your peloton journey go
to one
peloton dot com to learn more that's o
n e p e l o t o n
dot c o m the name you can trust
you know i saw i want to thank everyone
for hitting the hotline 985-664-9503
and for submitting unique videos and
things to discuss here and there's a
website here
uh someone sent a video in of a woman
uh who found a stranger living in her
house
okay backstory i live alone in a house
i have a house to myself nobody lives
here
nobody lives here okay there's a woman
in her bathroom talking about being
lonesome and uh that no one
lives at her home and this woman seems
i don't want to say vegan but definitely
uh
you know kind of lady that kind of uh
starts to some people if they get too
vegan or out there they'll start to look
like christmas trees they have a lot of
ornaments and
knackery on them my friends come over
occasionally
but not super often i mostly go to my
friend's houses
nobody uses my shower okay nobody
first of all every time i'm home i hear
the weirdest noises which happens
all the time that's like unexplainable
and i just like brush it off because i'm
like whatever
but this is my final straw i literally
i'm like freaking out right now i came
home wanting to take a shower
just got off work all i wanted to do was
take a shower open my shower curtain
someone lives in my house and has brown
hair my hair is pink
and there you go at the end she realizes
based on hair color that somebody and
you
you can't see on the video they pan down
and there's an eyebrow or something in
the tub
and to me this seemed like it's a uh
who is a lady uh no
um it could be a damn um
a little mercantile what's that lady's
name uh low
um um
oh her name she's like uh
i uh
uh oh uh missy uh
no little let me see highest
engrossing female rappers
nicki minaj i feel like it looked like
nicki minaj is in there
lost a damn eyebrow or something
but she said it's a man's hair i it
sounded like that
but this lady also may not even she
seemed like a real uh
i don't she'd find a damn eyebrow in the
tub but she said she's been
hearing weird stuff this is the final
straw
like if you like
if there's like uh you know somebody
even making muffins they
left a bowl you know a um
muffin stuff
you know stuff and out on your counter
then you got to
call the police i mean you can't you
can't be like hmm
what is this huh i want
is there somebody making muffin am i
sleep muffining
like she said this is the final straw
the final whether i just wonder what
some of the other straws were
you know i wonder what some of the other
straws were where you finally found a
piece of mustache in the tub
and now the guy's obviously changed his
you know
whatever intel you had on him earlier
this guy shaved his hair this guy's
changing the game up
you know he could have dyed his skin
you know you could be looking for
somebody who's jaundice next month i
mean who knows
but i think one way to do it here's how
i would do it
because obviously this dude does drugs
or whatever
and if you're willing to hide in
somebody's house
if you're willing to be out there to
stray goldie locking
or male goldilock i mean that's the s
here's what i would do i would stand
against the wall young lady
and i would just start counting i would
put my hands on my face i'd like one
two
and i think maybe it'll
then maybe they'll think it's a game
or maybe just stand in the living room
like you know what i can't find you
i can't find you
i don't know how do you but
it's crazy put a little trap out
you know here's a way to find out if the
man is thinking of anything sexual
if it's a rapist or not get your little
mouse trap put a little
condom on it and if he
you know if you hear that thing pop off
at night you know a
you caught him and b
he's a rapist baby so but i wish you
well it's sad to see that men are now
the goldilocks in america
you know you got this lady out here kind
of got that t-pain vibe and you got men
out here goldilocks
but that's god's plan baby and that's
where we are praise god baby
and thank you guys i found that one out
there that video
we got some other ones that came in from
uh from our listeners i want to thank
you guys for hitting the hotline as
always
um i'm getting excited about this tour
uh i'm gonna figure that out i'm also
i'm gonna take
i'm gonna take a little bit of time and
go to a look do a little bit of like a
retreat
and do some um
just deal with some try and deal with
some stuff i've been dealing with
you know over the past year i've talked
about it maybe a year and a half even
i've just really been dealing with some
anger issues
you know and i'm not trying to be a
debbie downer
but it's affected a lot of the way that
i communicate and that i feel
um and it's affected the amount of
joy and stuff that i'm having in my life
and so i want to be a little bit more uh
proactive
and so i'm gonna just see about maybe 10
days or something
you know and it's nothing where they're
electrocuting you or something
you know it's nothing where they beating
you or anything or i'm astounding people
or anything it's real
i think it's just going to be an
organized thing where you can kind of
focus
and so that's what that's what i'm
excited about i'm i'm trying to stay
excited
you know i literally have to commit to a
pl to a spot when i get off of the
podcast today and so i'm a little scared
i guess
uh
i think my my biggest thing is do i
really want to feel better
sometimes
you know sometimes it's like do i really
want to feel better
and i'm not saying that as a downer i'm
not trying to bring anybody down
like this podcast isn't about bringing
anybody down
but i damn i sometimes i just i want to
i have to be able to share what i'm
thinking or feeling
um
and yeah you know i'm just so hard on
myself all the time i just want to start
to figure what i have to i have to find
some
you know i want to do some excavating
there and just see what's going on
and at the same time keep moving forward
you know
my mother sometimes talks to me about
well don't sit in the past you know
don't sit in the past
and some of that is super true
you know um but it's sometimes it's also
hard to really
you know i notice whatever things from
my past are affecting me from having
like
committed relationships um
you know feeling okay um
[Music]
being willing to dance at weddings i
don't like doing that honestly
i've been so scared about dancing at a
wedding sometimes i wish that somebody
will stand up during the nuptials or
whatever and say
and protest so at least we won't have to
dance you know so yeah i don't know
but i'm hopeful and um
and everything's fine i'm not like in a
bad place i'm actually in an okay place
but i want to take us some time and just
kind of see what's going on um
and i have a little bit of time i have a
little bit of space and so i'm thankful
to god that i have this a little bit of
space in my life where i can
kind of investigate and i can share with
you whatever i'm seeing or thinking
you know and uh and that really feels
like a gift
and thank you guys for your support man
so many supportive people
you know what i want to be able to do i
want to be able to be a part of like a
some solution in the world
you know i don't know what that means
exactly uh
but i think you know it's like
i think we're in a weird place in
society where we realize maybe
that all these things we're getting
aren't really they're great and they're
cool and it's nice to have successes but
if we don't have
a bigger feeling of success inside of
ourself or comfort
you know it's almost like uh
it's almost like an awakening in a way
where we realize oh there's got to be
more out there
than this box set of wherever
or this me undies subscription you know
or these two you know 12 you know these
24 inch speakers
um so anyway i don't know
you know me man i'm always
hitchhiking out here inside of my own
heart
so uh gang baby and that's okay that's
who i am bro
i'm a sensitive fella man but i'm also a
bad mf er dog
you know what i'm saying dude and i'll
hog tie your cousin dog
and remodel that dude's lips fam
praise god bruh
don't even try me dude i'll restack your
spine baby call me jimmy jenga dude
and i'll give you that slipped disc much
so don't even put it past me
uh what else is going on a lot of good
calls that came in and
um a lot of great people involved with
this podcast man
and you know one of the things i noticed
over the year over the past year and a
half is sometimes when i listen to
people i can't hear them as good
like i can hear him but i used to be
able to hear him and feel them
and i missed that man
you know i miss that and i don't know
what inside of me is making me
uncomfortable you know we're making me
but when i hear when i see people or i
hear people and somebody's talking and
they're sharing something that's
important to them and i want to be able
to
hear it and feel it and
and yeah i just i want to be able to do
that and and
i don't know in and it's just important
to me
you know it's important to me um
yeah so that's okay you know this is
this a journey that i'm on and i'm
grateful to be on it
you know that's another thing i do
believe that my higher power has like a
plan for me that's
uh that means something
and for you too i do believe there's a
reason that we're all right here
listening to this right now
because i can feel you listening to you
know
and uh yeah i
i don't know man i don't know but praise
god bro
ptl baby you know that baby get in there
it's so funny we were doing a show the
other night and thank you to everybody
that came out there in los
angeles the other night man we had a fun
show and um
because this guy stands up in the back
man just fell it
and uh he's like let's go people are all
excited
but it's so weird at a comedy show
there's nothing to kind of to do it's
like
we're all fired up but there's nothing
to do you know uh
except like sit back down and listen
so it's just the weirdest dichotomy man
it's a weird uh or whatever they call it
dichotomy dichotomy one of the other oh
i got this bad smoothie damn
oh
oh my god oh
is it is is this a in this
this thing has a real enema type feel to
it
um i wash it down with some liquid death
you know that dude i've been watching
that softball
let's go boy i've been watching
softball dude am i a lesbian
oh my gosh i've been watching that s
ball baby
a lot of thicky thicks out there with
them sticky sticks you know that
dang i mean you could see i wish you
kind of knew the menstrual cycle of the
team so you were like oh okay these
these girls they got a little grudge
they got that grudge it would be like a
grudge flow factor
okay you know they showed like the moon
the moon going whatever you know these
girls are half moon and over here
and these is wolverine and over
here
but my god you know i i i i just love
watching it
i love watching the softball man
i like seeing him thighs i like stalking
the girls on instagram i like doing it
all
you know you're with your girl she's
like what are you doing on your phone
you're like i don't know
jm you just hit a homer
you know you're just getting in there
man
and this girl and dude one thing that's
interesting to the crowd at the softball
game
is you could hear all these chirpers a
lot of women out there
not a lot of uh
not a lot of fear not a lot of uh
you know a lot of real bird on bird
action
a lot of ladies that like to uh
you know what i'm saying it's taco
tuesday
four days a week you know what i'm
saying you know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying ah
i'm downstairs you know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying
[Applause]
so oh yeah it's just fun to guess
like who's really you know out there
wallet hop and you see some of the
ladies you know in the stands and they
just really
um those biscuit friskers you know what
i'm saying these ladies out there they
just checking wallet on a lot of these
girls and
but it's all beautiful man it's all love
you know
and happy gay pride and it's uh man i
just damn love softball
and the girl montana fouts through a
damn
unlimited strikeouts or whatever it's
called like
jeepers you know and it's just funny you
see they
all everybody out there they doing it
and you see in the distance you know
big tiffany's in the distance and she's
stunting like my daddy
you know what i'm saying she got some
you know she's just out there manny
fresh and it's just really
god it's good man i mean what a and it's
just fun to watch you know it just
there's a lot of action in those games
there's a lot of like excitement by the
ladies
whereas the guys they're it's a little
more too cool for school a lot of time
with the guys
you know it's all tobacco and spitting
and you know
or gum or whatever but the ladies
they're they
they got the cheers and the chants and
the
they're doing it all and they're
touching tits i mean i saw two of them
jump up in the air and just damn touched
hits brother
you know i don't
imagine they'll jump start a civic baby
with them milk knuckles baby let's go
and here's one here's one right here
this is uh thank you for sending this in
this is naked woman destroys outback
[Music]
this breaks my heart man first of all
first of all lady you in here we just
got restaurants
open lady
we just got them open
and you know how hard it is to get
anything imported right now
huh and you out here at outback
okay you out here at the australian
uh what is it called center of
teamwork um you're out here at the
australian consulate
in wherever this is buffalo new york
and you can't handle yourself
this is why we can't have nice things
look at her
oh and she's naked look at this
you don't bring a bloomin onion to a
bloomin onion honey
okay good christ
oh and the guy asked he said look
this is the worst part about having to
work at a corporate thing
he goes ma'am please
and she don't get it she don't get it
little tiffany can't tighten up
for one minute she's out here showing
that slick wallet to everybody
at the dang outback
my favorite part there's a woman waiting
in the distance
there's a woman there's a woman
waiting to be seated still in the foyer
she's gonna stay and ride it out
she's like you know i drove over here
i'm gonna still see if they can get me
[Music]
in
oh and you can see a little bit of booty
right there damn boy
shorty got that back smile damn
now here comes the officer baby let's go
oh yeah
oh this is like csi australia dude this
is it
she's throwing stuff at this cop what
and i want to apologize to australia man
we
you know we better than this one we
better
than this
she just told the cop when i'm at a club
that she is treated a certain type of
way
well this is australia
okay and your little woke ass about to
go to sleep
and he he freaking he let her up baby
that's that december 25th baby he gave
her that freaking
that pistol christmas daddy you feel me
she got tased up
you could see her just hit them
kookaburra wings dog
whoo that's what you get that's what you
get ladies when your dad
doesn't uh you know
kind of teach you how to do stuff
properly and right there
and that's probably addiction right
there as well but shout out australia
man we love you guys and um you know
with that's not us
that's that and uh we
ain't her so
i love you guys and i can't wait to get
back over to australia and i'm sorry
about everything with that lady
dang boy he gave her that signature
sampler boy
and she broke all that dishway we just
got restaurants open
and this is what you do
i hope they spray that broad down with
covid
here's one other that came in jollibee
faces backlash after a customer receives
deep fried towel
instead of fried chicken philippine fast
food chain jollibee yo libby
is facing backlash after a customer
allegedly received a deep fried towel
instead of its famous crispy fried
chicken
you know people say they want to eat
clean but do they
really want to eat clean
that's really all i got out on that um
what else we got here man some other
nice things that came in
let me uh get to a question from one of
you guys and um
thank you for it uh
here we go hey you man this is uh
this is evan i'm living out red wing
minnesota southeast
saint paul minneapolis here oh yeah
out there near r near red wing man and
red wing is definitely uh
that's that menstrual cycle bird you
know what i'm saying baby we actually
dip it
we actually dip into a slip one time
when she's taken off
and then you know you uh
you know it's a little bit of um you're
gonna have a little bit of a
turbulence on the course baby when you
got that heavy wing a little bit ironed
out
and also having that area where you live
is uh or where you are that's
where uh uh
billy valens died uh richie valens
and the big bopper they died over there
in that plane crash
a lot of people don't remember that by
the movie la bamba
and hate to spoil the ending but um
they died there in uh kind of the on the
iowa minnesota border around there
and i believe it's down near where you
are what else we got onward evan thank
you minneapolis here
right off the old mighty mississippi
river i'm just kind of looking for some
advice for me you know i've been seeing
this girl for a few months
and she took off today for basic
training
for the uh for the military she's going
to be the national guard
and uh you know i know i'm gonna have
some down time i'm gonna
you know be kind of bumming or whatever
um but i you know i go fishing a lot
maybe that might be my way to kind of
unwind and
get my mind off things but i just kind
of looking like what you've done maybe
if it's been like a long distance
relationship or just
knowing you're going to be away from
someone you care about for a long time
how you kind of dealt with that because
uh
you know it's only three months and
they'll end you know it's not that bad
but uh there's no way for me to
communicate with her
but letters you know you can't talk to
him on the cell phone or nothing but uh
i'm just kind of reaching out to you man
looking for uh for kind of
your wisdom or your advice on the topic
if you haven't experienced
well thank you man you know i've long
cheated on every woman i've ever dated
and been a
you know been a real dirt diver over
there
you know i run across the yard to smell
something that's the kind of animal i am
uh but um
but i have had some moments when i was
in love also where i behaved as a
as a as a lover you know
i mean and you can be two things you
know you can be
someone who's loving and caring can also
be at the same time someone who hasn't a
you know an affliction and really gives
in to those dark arts
of touching titty you know of reaching
for that third top
when your ladies already got two you
know
are reaching for that second hand rail
when your man's already weaned up
and um
and you know i used to do some nice
things man i remember i gave this girl a
nice box of like
candies and different things like you
know kind of like
i don't remember like i do remember but
i'm just ashamed to say i made like a
nice buy i had like all these like
little fires in it and like
it was like you know i got the hots for
you and it had some red hots in that
and a little fire engine
clifford the dog little tickle me alma
you know had a gauze kit for like a burn
victim type of thing in there
had some uh aloe vera in there
everything
you know picture of a skin graft surgery
or something that i printed
back when the printer ink it was like
you know you got you put
you printed one thing and you had to go
get get a new ink and your dad was
pissed and your stepdad was also pissed
dude and
he wasn't even really your stepdad he
was a man letting you live at his home
um but uh
i think do be sweet you know it's funny
because i was just talking in the
beginning now about how there's no
connection there's no ability to be a
storyteller
this is a chance for you to be that
you know whether this relationship works
out or not which i hope it does
and thank your lady for her service but
this is a chance for you to
i don't know explore how you feel about
when she is gone
you know how you make me feel like this
you know or this is some things i think
about
and also try to have some respect for
yourself and not overdo it
you know you don't need to write every
day that's too much of responsibility
you know
um but it sounds like you guys have a
pretty good foundation you don't sound
really concerned about that you just
sound
uh like you're just thinking about how
to handle it
and what i've done man is yeah just done
some nice things try to do some
thoughtful things
um you know try to like include
sometimes her family or something and
you know make like a nice little deal
for send it
uh yeah it's a different time now we're
the goldilocks you know a lot of men's
are at home
and women out there doing electricity
and doing
you know working at the blood bank or
whatever
so but i just think it's nice that you
even care bro
that's nice a lot of people be like damn
i hope they send this girl a fight in
iraq because i'm ready for a break you
know
so i think it's beautiful just
for us to take that moment to see that
you care evan and um
and yeah i think it's this is also a
good opportunity for you to do some
things you want to do
you don't have that time when you have
that that that immediate constant
day-to-day connection
you know it's hard to get your hands
dirty if you got to high-five somebody
every day with a clean hand
so this is a chance for you to maybe do
something new
learn how to do a cheese or something a
gruyere
you know learn how to provolone you feel
me
by yourself
you know you can learn how to bake and
learn how to shuffle or learn how to do
magic a lot of you could do
praise god baby good luck over there man
i think you got it
i think you can do just fine man
but don't just take care of her also
take care of you
what else we got here we go kevin from
houston
hey seo is kevin uh from houston texas i
wanted to
let you know about a uh encounter i had
with a
fellow this past weekend enthusiast uh
so i'm a pest technician and
my last stop of the day it was pouring
rain in houston um
i really didn't want to do it i could
have called and called out and
and not done it for the rain but i
thought you know let me just see what
this guy's problem is you know i want to
take care of it
if he needs me to take care of your
singer i like that
you know those i went to a restaurant
the other day they said they can't even
find any workers right now
at the restaurant that people don't even
want to work so anybody that's doing a
job man i commend you thanks kevin
onward
um so i got there started talking to him
about his
his uh problems or whatnot i looked down
and we got a lot of pest problems and it
sounds like the dude had one of the
ultimate pests maybe theo von gang
and what do i see but a theoren dark
arts tour shirt
and i stopped miss citizens because it
doesn't matter what i was saying before
i was like dude i love seo vaughn and he
stuck that little hand out
that little fist and he goes dang and we
fit something yeah
and and i gotta tell you that made my
entire day and i just want to let you
know you're affecting people everywhere
from uh from covington to houston so uh
keep it up man gang kevin thank you man
thanks for sharing that dude that's
awesome and if that guy hasn't paid his
bill yet man will you please call into
the hotline i'm gonna uh see if we can't
pay that pest control man
because you know that dude has he
probably he's infested with the dark
arts baby if he's got that
if he's got that tour shirt sitting
there um
i'm gonna tell you about this man fiverr
if you haven't used this this is a very
good thing to use if you had an extra
eighth day of the week what would you do
you know i'd probably do some spray
painting or something some light
graffiti
i would organize things i'd find the
smell in my truck
that smelled like a banana i'd get a new
logo for this past week and help us
divide
design some t-shirts i would do
different things like that
um and i find more i find ways to be
more a part of other people's lives
well if you're a business owner you
probably know exactly what you do with
an extra day each week maybe you launch
a new website spend more time on
marketing with your services or
find new more creative ways to build
your brand
but you don't need an extra day what you
really need is fiverr
f-i-v-e-r-r your one-stop shop for
world-class
freelance talent uh ari manis
who's been my opener on the road he uses
fiverr a lot
he's we've used fiverr to hire people to
help with different things
with fiverr all the freelancers you
could ever need are right at your
fingertips
if you wonder who can do this who in my
area you don't have to always at you
know
post on facebook does anybody know
anybody
that could build a um a retaining wall
go to fiverr that's right fiverr's
global network of on-demand freelance
talent is here
whether you're launching your first
business scaling your current business
or in need of extra support
from graphic design copywriting
marketing web programming
film editing scoring music and more so
actually fiverr is more
centered on the uh electronical side the
digital side you need somebody to help
you
put some music together you've written a
song you need somebody to help you track
it
you have a website idea an app an app
idea
you need a consultor you need someone
who can
help you get the right infrastructure
going on for your business that's
through fiverr 24 7 customer service
reach out with questions anytime
anywhere check out
fiverr.com and receive 10
off your first order by using our code
theo
find all the digital services in one
place at f i v
e r r dot com slash theo that's
fiverr.com theo thank you for supporting
the podcast you know many americans uh
struggle with insurance purchasing and
i'm one of them
you know i purchased some insurance and
i'm changing it now saving some money
i am i'm going to save almost a thousand
dollars over the next year
and that's good yup and one of your
biggest purchases of the year is
insurance and who can help you save
the zebra the zebra is the nation's
leading insurance comparison site for
car and home insurance
that's it in minutes you can compare
policies from every major provider for
free
all on one independent marketplace after
a few quick questions the zebra pairs
people
with the right insurance company for
them helping everyone save time
and money yep best of all the zebra has
no stake in the policy
you choose nope they have no stake in it
they don't get any backhanded deal
they're just helping you out after a few
quick questions
the zebra pairs people with the right
insurance company for them
helping you save time and money visit
the zebra.com t-h-e-o to get your free
quote
today that's t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a
dot com slash theo the zebra.com
theo make sure there isn't some
insurance savings out there for you
you know what let's hit a wind that came
out today let's hit a win
we want to get some wins on the board
man and uh
and let's hear one right here here we go
howdy man uh
this is a little cross between a a big
big win and a little bit of
tip for you you know you're talking
about how you're thinking about settling
down maybe getting something going and
what worked for me man i was throughout
my 20s and like my you know late teens
and all that i was
partying living for the weekend didn't
even realize it just kind of
and i wasn't i wasn't finding the
meaning you know i thought i would find
it there and
and i was and what happened for me was i
was getting lots of girls
but not the girl the girl would always
be i just couldn't get her that she
would never be interested in me the way
i would look like obsessed with her i'd
fall in love with these girls and
they'd never go for me i'm a good
looking guy man trust me over the phone
but trust me i
got all these other girls but i didn't
really respect it
you sound decent because much and it was
just like
no homo either brother praise god happy
pride but also nh
i think that you get what you put in you
get
in what you put out and so i changed my
ways i actually found christ
and i came to know him more i cleaned my
cup act up and
what do you know like exactly all i
dreamed up fell into my lap man my
life's been so amazing ever since we're
married now
we're talking about kids and oh man i
pray for you man i pray that you get the
happiness that uh i could experience
thank you brother i appreciate that man
yeah i mean look
if he if you even look at the first
chapter of the lord's uh
novella if you look at that first
chapter he you know
he had a he two people blind dated a
damn olive garden dude
in the olive garden of eden baby two
people he bded him
he blind dated him right there damn lady
orders apples right out of the gate and
goes haywire
and somebody damn and there's a snake on
the premises you know and they gotta
call down pest control and you know and
the two guys end up realizing their theo
von fans there but
um but no i appreciate it man you know
and
and uh yeah i i just
you know it's funny i i want different
things in my life and but it's
i'm all so comfortable and man we made
it
it all makes things so comfortable these
days
you know it's just like a damn people
just serving comfort caves
and i'm just in there i'm just sitting
here by you know between two boulders
with a with a met with a book of matches
you know we make it so comfortable each
person
separate comfortable sedate
oh you got a sexual feeling jerk out
you know bust out oh you got this go
don't worry here's this you got a
headache you got a tickle
are you ticklish i saw a pill yesterday
online are you ticklish
then get this pill you shouldn't have to
live that way
what what way
shouldn't you have to live in laughter
it is a battle it is a war
but i appreciate you man you're right
and it takes effort and it takes
adjustment nothing
changes if nothing changes you know
we do what we can here and um and uh uh
you know let's keep it moving here and
let's let's let's let's
you know keep the light where it is and
that's moving forward
in front of us um if you're struggling
out there man know that i love you
you know and know that you are loved and
sometimes people are reaching for you
and you gotta
you gotta you gotta put your hand out
you know you don't you don't have to
meet him halfway but sometimes you gotta
meet him at least
five percent of way you know and you can
do it
you can do it man um thank you guys for
being a part of my life
and uh and and i want to say you know we
do what we can here to to be a
positive thing in the world and we got a
single mom uh nomination that came in
right here let's get to it
hey theo it's alec here south
mississippi man i have a single mother i
like to select her name is janae sevedra
she just went through her second round
of chemo i believe she's battling cancer
she has a sweet little boy man and she's
sweet herself and she's just been heavy
on my heart my mind
so i thought why not submit a video man
if you're seeing this
love your brother thanks for all you do
love the show gang gang baby
gang baby there you go and that man is
up there you can see that man does uh
he got the hard hat on he might be a
damn
i mean he could be a coal miner doing a
hell he could be doing an industrial
microwave he'd do an industrial size
microwave that could
that dude could be have a boat or be
cooking up the damn biggest uh
tostito pizza roll you've ever seen
you know you just don't know what a lot
of these people are doing nowadays but
let's see if we can't get janae on the
line here man
and yeah thanks for the submission and
for brightening up my day man as always
you can submit things through
theovonne.com
videos for us to talk about to discuss
things you've recorded
um single mom nominations uh questions
you want to have possibly on the show
anything like that
hello hey janae hey can you hear me
i can hear you hey um my name's theo i
just work on a podcast
um and we do a thing where some of our
listeners sometimes will call in
um and they want to suggest like a
single mom that they know
who is who just who they really admire
so we had a guy named alec call in and i
don't know if he works at like a
carnival or he might do like railroad
work or something but he um
he uh nominated you and so we just
wanted to send you a thousand dollars to
do something fun with your kiddo
um thank you so much
you're very welcome um you said
what have you been up to what's going on
with you right now in your world
um currently um i'm at home i was
diagnosed with uh hodgkin's lymphoma
no is it hard is it scary
it was scary it was well the way i kind
of found out about it was by accident
um so at that point it was stage two so
it wasn't
wasn't as bad as what it could have been
but um
but i've been going through chemotherapy
and um may 7th
is when i had my last pet scan and so
that will show
kind of how much cancer is still there
if there's any there
and the scans showed that there was
nothing there yeah
but i still have to go through uh
treatment though and then um
also when i found out that i had cancer
um i found out that i have
bell's palsy too so i don't know if you
can tell like the right side of my face
is just temporarily paralyzed
really is no telling when that will
self-correct itself
but um but yeah since march i just been
kind of staying
at home and i haven't really been able
to work because my uh
my white cell count is really low and
i'm more susceptible to
you know get sick easier so i'm more at
risk especially
with covid and all that stuff they want
me to stay at home
and how are you able to stay positive
during this like what's what's some of
that been like if you don't mind sharing
some of that i don't know
well i have a really awesome group of
people my family
um they have been you know the people
that helped me get through each and
every day
um and it's been a blessing really to
have those people in my life
without them i couldn't have done as far
as i am now for sure
yeah what is that like like how much
does that influence you know or affect
you you feel like like what is
like what are some things that people do
that that really kind of let you know
that
you have support um you know i've had
people text me
um you know single mom i have
my son brent you know does brett need
anything do you need me to pick him up
from school do you need to
you know make dinner for you or is there
anything that i can do that can help you
know your day-to-day
um that's been a really you know big
help in my life is
just knowing that i have people out
there that are willing to take time out
of their day to help me
yeah yeah it's big it's so important
people just knowing that other people
care about them you know
right exactly it's a big thing um my
friend that bell's palsy dude actually
it was pretty
yeah i mean not to say it was cool but i
always kind of admired it i like things
that are a little different so
yeah i don't think it's cool i'm so over
it it's been like three months but
really what does it feel like can you
whistle no i can't whistle i can't
i really it's it's crazy um i can barely
drink through a straw like it's just i
don't know it's weird
does it feel like does it almost feel
like when you're at the dentist actually
and they kind of give you that
stuff wow yeah it does um sometimes
though like if i use that muscle a lot
it'll kind of tingle a little bit
like it feels like it's it's wanting to
do something but it it just can't i
don't know it's really weird i've never
had that feeling before
oh yeah i've definitely uh
i've definitely wanted to do things but
not been able to do them but um
dang so what about your son so he goes
to school
yeah well right now he's uh he's in like
pre-k he goes to daycare
he'll he'll start kindergarten um in the
fall oh pre-k is pretty easy i think
yeah oh yeah yeah he's doing good
is he yeah he's doing real well oh
that's nice
um well uh yeah we just wanted to say
hey and let you know we just want to be
a part of
something positive in your day today and
your friend alec really cares about you
and
uh and yeah we're just going to be
cheering you on and
when do you get that next uh pet scan
that i'm not sure um we're kind of just
doing it um
by ear we're just playing it by ear
right now so i'll go back to the
oncologist
next tuesday and depending on how my
blood level looks and my blood work
looks um it'll determine whether or not
they will continue with treatment or not
um but my oncologist has to make that
call but once i'm
done with the chemo treatments they tell
me i have treatments left
um and then i'll get another scan but
we'll just have to see so it could be it
could be soon i don't know
that's cool they got them dogs now that
could smell cancer they said but i don't
know if i trust them
no yeah you could just have a damn beef
jerky in your pocket and next thing you
know you test positive you know
i have cats too so they could probably
smell the cat and they mistake it for
you know
the cat but yeah next thing you know you
in treatment and this is because you're
a pet owner you know
right exactly yeah that seems like a
little bit unnecessary but
well look when that bells wears off you
send us a picture of you with a full
smile how about that
awesome i sure will thank you so much oh
you bet and go do something fun with
brent and um
and you have a good day we love you
thank y'all thank y'all so much
yep bye-bye bye
and there you go right there you know
nice to see a young lady stand so
positive man
that's a thing you know
that lady she's out there she got she
can't even do a full smile for a kid
right now part of her face is taking a
you know the summer off or whatever and
she's got to do
you know she's just getting it done
and that's pretty positive thank you
guys for being here with me today you
know what i'm saying i'm
upstairs if you need me
baby you know where i'll be you know
i'm going to be just keeping on going on
you know i did some treadmilling earlier
and
i saw a damn bluebird this morning
so i know the lord's got my bag baby and
i'm out there and i'm out there baby you
know that and i'm about to roll my quads
out with a quad roller
and really i got them jostles up in my
damn
eyes make me down i just feel so damn
thotty
you know i god but
uh thank everybody for being a part of
this episode i want to thank our uh
our sponsor liquid death i want to thank
you um
you know we'll make sure that we have
episodes coming up even if i
am out of town we're gonna make some
this weekend
uh with some neat guests uh really
excited about it
and uh yeah that's all you know be good
to yourself
um you know
you deserve it uh and be good to each
other man we try
god i want to you know i get in a place
where i just gotten angry sometimes and
i want to just be better
i want to be better at it so and i don't
think i'm being hard on myself i want to
this is it this is the rodeo dog you
know
and i want to freaking know the whole
cattle you know that
uh we had this this uh there's a
gentleman akira the don
and he's a music man and uh he made this
he took a piece of a podcast and has
made some uh different
different things and one of them is uh
this right there called i can't make you
like me and um and it's from pieces of
old uh
from this past weekend and and thank you
to everybody
uh thank you to those two fellows that
met up in a in a pest infested
living room to fist bump uh
thank you to everybody that's ever you
know been to a hot tub
and seen somebody who was pretending to
be a child but was probably an adult
he you know masturbate out into their
water
you know thank you to everybody who
loves people
and if it's hard for you to love man i i
know how you feel
um and just know that you're not alone
baby
gang we got this
[Music]
when i was in middle school that's fifth
grade